we're just overlooking the 401 here take
a look at the conditions right now you
can see traffic is moving but it is slow
you can also see the roads have already
been plowed but don't let that fool you
even though there is not a lot of snow
on the roads right now there are some
areas that are still quite slippery so
keep that in mind
don't
try to drive too quickly just because
there's not a lot of snow on the road
and we're really seeing a lot of cars
slipping and sliding and some cases
veering off the roads even this morning
police responding to a lot of minor
collisions in and around the greater
toronto area we know that
the weather has also played a role
in a fatal collision that took place on
the qew in hamilton last night that was
when the snow was still falling and
visibility could have been tricky in
some parts now around town we know that
city crews here in toronto have been out
and about trying to clear the roads
hundreds of salters and plows have been
out city officials say let those
vehicles do their jobs
[Applause]
oh